what's going on guys this is rob and if
you recall i previously talked about how
i wanted to introduce the opportunity
for other people on youtube that have a
channel that's smaller than mine to gain
some notoriety for their channel by
having their content uploaded to my
youtube channel i know this is a little
strange as a little take away or i guess
a little break away from what you are
normally used to but I've been in
youtube for a while and I know how
difficult it can be to grow on you too
but I know that there are some people
out there who just won't really see
their content by anybody just because of
the fact that it's so difficult to gain
exposure on youtube I think that I
happen to luck out I think that I happen
to maybe be at the right place at the
right time but more so than that i also
found myself for I guess I yeah I found
myself coming across some great
individual some great people who in turn
were able to help my channel grow and
now I feel like a majority of my success
is due to these subscribers that I have
and I wanted to extend the opportunity
to other youtubers to present themselves
to the fan base that I have present
themselves to the people who are
watching my videos and two more or less
give them a reason why they should check
out their channel why it is that the
people who are part of my youtube
channel should check out their channel
as well now there are a few guidelines
here the first guideline is that I ask
that you keep your videos under 10
minutes and the reason for this is
because my videos are extensive they can
be anywhere between 25 and 30 minutes
but my videos go very very in depth
about a very particular thing and I
think that when it comes to presenting
yourself as far as and a commentator
that people are interested in listening
to that you should try to keep it
concise try to give them a really short
spiel as to what it is your channel is
about and then I guess reserve the
longer and the more in-depth content for
your own channel the next thing is I am
NOT going to filter any of the comments
regarding my regarding pupils comments
here on YouTube I'm not going to ask
them not to say certain things I'm not
going to ask them not to do certain
things you're going to experience the
full force the full brunt of the fan
base on my youtube channel and so if you
have a comic book channel and then you
make a video and you submitted to me and
for whatever reason it happens to get
through
you're basically going on about nonsense
because I will watch the YouTube videos
that are being submitted to me then my
my fan base is immediately going to find
that out there immediately going to
realize that you don't know what you're
talking about and they're going to
reflect that distaste both with this lot
of dislikes and with comments on that
YouTube video and I don't want you all
to feel disheartened I don't want you
all to get on here and to have your
video submitted and then to turn around
and be lambasted by people who are part
of my my you tube fan base the next
thing is don't use vulgarity I don't
want my channel to be a pleasure people
are cussing and screaming and carrying
on if you have videos where you're
ranting and raving and you're screaming
and cussing and so on I'm going to drop
your video I'm not going to post it this
isn't you know because I want it to be
some kind of family-friendly youtube
channel is because I want you to act
like a reasonable human being and if you
can't do that then your video is not
going to be posted the next thing is
this is for all different kinds of
videos this isn't simply just Marvel
Comics this isn't simply just DC Comics
if you have video blogs if you do video
blogs and you like to talk about certain
things then send the video to me if you
play video games then send the video to
me if you like to run in the park and
talk about what you're thinking about as
you're running then send the video to me
if it's anything that your channel is
based on then send the video to me and I
will go through it and if I'm satisfied
with a content that you've produced then
i will upload it the next thing is if
you do video blogs have a good quality
webcam if you do any kind of audio have
a good quality microphone i'm not going
to accept a video with a microphone
audio is grainy and it's very difficult
to understand you and your words seem
slurred and so on and so forth because
all this going to do is frustrate my fan
base and people just aren't going to
have anything to do with it i want to
make sure that people who are submitting
their content here are going to get the
best possible reception they can and in
this day and age in youtube there's
really no excuse to not have a high
quality microphone or a high quality
webcam
as far as it goes that's pretty much it
i'm sure that new idea is a new animal
to call them regulations but more or
less that those things will be
established as time goes on and i really
hope this is going to be a great success
i really hope this is going to give
people who are smaller on youtube a
chance to grow and to really expand I
don't ask that you're a subscriber I'm
not one of these people that says that
you need to subscribe to my channel to
have your video submitted not at all
this isn't some attempt for me to gain
subscribers or anything along those
lines this is simply just a chance for
individuals who were smaller on YouTube
to have the opportunity to grow more by
exposing themselves or I guess to to
talking to a larger audience than they
would normally be able to do on their
own with that being said i look forward
to some awesome videos and I will catch
you guys later peace
you